this is funny because you're all right  sitting there i think this is working um  three of us here this is the uh call it  the brain trust  of the linguist linguist nerve center  nerve center we have uh standing up uh  mark  who is the fellow who's putting putting  all the specifications together the only  person who's not here is the one who's  working and doing the programming he's  not allowed to leave his desk he's  changed his desk  24 hours a day  and uh jill  hello  jill is our uh  number one  mama  looking after all her little children  so what did you guys say mama  mama has been hot mama  oh i like the sounds a lot  uh what do i have to say um  well i don't know about what  can't think of anything to say  and raised